mais c'est un problème qui pancanadien
aussi alors qu'est-ce que les autres
provinces font pour tenter d'enrayer
cette violence céline s'il ya bien deux
provinces qui était frappé de plein
fouet par ce problème c'est bien la
colombie-britannique 1 il suffit de
penser à la violence quotidienne que
vivent les femmes autochtones qui
viennent des réserves vont à vancouver
dans le quartier d'anthony sad où elles
subissent les problèmes de la
prostitution de la toxicomanie et tout
ceci bien sûr amener aussi au fameux
procès de robert pickton le tueur en
série de ces femmes
on pourrait penser également aussi à la
fameuse autoroute des larmes qui relie
vancouver après saint georges dans le
nord de la province oulaï énormément de
femmes qui ont subi de la violence et
qui ont six disparus alors tout ceci en
fait a donné lieu à une énorme
commission denquête en colombie
britannique
et tout ceci a donné notamment un
rapport sur les femmes disparues avec
une soixantaine de recommandations qui
ont été pour certaines plus ou moins mis
en place il ya quand même eu certaines
certains programmes et stratégies qui
visait un peu à réduire cette violence
envers les femmes autochtones
il y avait également des campagnes de
prévention et de sensibilisation et
surtout on essaie d'améliorer les
relations entre ces femmes et la police
parce que souvent ces femmes là selon
les autochtones passer pour des
citoyennes de deuxième classe
alors ce sont des stratégies qui ont été
suivis dans plusieurs provinces
l'alberta saskatchewan au manitoba
mais de l'aveu même des autochtones en
général il trouve que c'est assez
insuffisant des plans d'action mais aux
résultats mitigés
pourtant certains statistiques donnent
vraiment froid dans le dos oui en fait
quand on remonte le temps entre 2001 et
2011 en fait 8 % des femmes assassinées
au canada étaient des femmes autochtones
alors qu'elles ne représentent en fait
seulement que 4% de la population
féminine total et puis quand on regarde
la violence conjugale maintenant mais on
se rend compte que ces femmes là ont
trois fois et demi plus de risques
d'être victimes de violence conjugale
que les femmes autochtones alors c'est
pour ça aussi évidemment que les
autochtones réclament à cor et à cri
bien sûr une enquête publique nationale
ça a toujours été refusée par le premier
ministre harper les premiers ministres
des provinces et les territoires sont
montés aux barricades pour dire mais non
nous nous sommes prêts à le faire là il
ya un changement de garde et ottawa
monsieur trudeau a promis une enquête
est ce que ça va donner lieu à quelque
chose on le verra est ce que ça
donnerait une commission avec un autre
rapport qui peut être sera plus ou moins
mis en place ou mis sur une tablette
ça l'avenir nous le dira céline merci
beaucoup frédéric a rempli